foreign
don't worry I know what I'm doing I saw
the first 15 minutes of the herlocker
hurry the Cinch is too much we gotta get
those shoes out of here
which time do we have Scully at his pot
pie 30 minutes ago so we probably got 10
minutes left on the snap 12. she's
turkey tired
it's trapped abort
I have an idea
but send these shoes to hell
oh wait man it just smells worse than
before
abort
[Music]
here something a little hairy
nope don't see anything out of the
ordinary really oh maybe I should
frame the question differently Terry do
you notice anything
Amy
new shirt oh come on guys I grew goatee
and it looks amazing and I know you can
see it of course we can see it Charles
it's horrible it looks like you
unclogged a shower drain with your mouth
yeah you look exactly like the guy in
the don't talk to strangers poster
no I don't are you talking about your
new goatee I think it's a good choice
for your face ah come over here so I can
take a better look thank you Captain I
knew you'd appreciate Bianca that's
right I call her Bianca because
cousin Bianca
Jeffers Peralta now
say goodbye to Bianca Boyle
ladies and gentlemen we are gathered
here today to answer an age-old question
right what's Amy's deal is she single no
we're dating come on the question is who
here does the best impression of Captain
Raymond Holt you'll be judged on voice
body language and overall lack of flair
everyone will perform the same scenario
Captain halt eating a marshmallow for
the very first time let the halt off
begin what is this glutinous monstrosity
before me sugariness is quite sweet
that's your whole impression I can hear
him doing that looks like a sticky
pillow I don't care for it classical
music
what's going on here what are you doing
Captain hey nothing just eating some
marshmallows careful one marshmallow
I knew it
[Music]
so I'm gonna had a good time in Paris oh
Kevin and I shared a perfect week
together I feel like I'm floating on a
croissant I wonder why people don't just
break in a song More Often I've been
asking you for months if I could answer
the phone like
give it a whirl girl
he's rhyming he's telling Gina to sing
can't hold is on a vacation high he will
say yes to anything right now I would
like a police horse and I'd like Terry
to be riding it almost constantly I like
an HR person to remind everyone about
workplace boundaries the Japanese make
toilet seats would squirt a heated jet
of water right up your I'm gonna stop
you right there bud what we need in here
is an armored personnel carrier a tank
two tanks I want a tank too great so
everyone gets a tank just remember we
can't ruin Captain Holt's vacation high
so no one say anything that'll upset him
oh no what are those morons doing in
there well maybe it's not that bad maybe
they didn't upset him what'd you do
what'd you say nothing we just said
welcome back and laughed with him about
all the weight he gained in France
why is everyone just standing around get
back to work
it's a long tank
I gained three pounds in Paris three
pounds
[Music]
do this golly you have to be stronger
right now what's going on Yoon is being
replaced come on that machine's been
here forever it's basically part of the
force take Scully instead yes please
take me to the land of vending machines
can we at least have five minutes to say
a proper goodbye
whatever
let me just start by saying that this
machine is the best restaurant in
Brooklyn and it always had a table for
me and you just were to punch it to get
free food you have to go back to
punching Hitchcock look she still has
the bags of baby carrots I requests that
they put in they're black now but
they're there goodbye beautiful machine
thank you for your service
okay
Squad salute
[Music]
you can take her away now
well I think we handled that with
dignity
free candy
[Applause]
Boyle's here this is so fun I wish you
guys got shot more often
back in the nine nine
welcome back detective wow is this all
for me of course it is what are you
wearing there buddy oh none of my pants
fit over my butt cast lucky for me my
mom lent me her leg warmers that is
lucky pretty sweet scooter oh yeah I
know check out these Donuts
oh that went terribly can I help you
with something nope nope everything's
under control
I picked up a couple Reacher Grabbers
yeah so I'm able to do everything that I
used to do so now if you'll excuse me
I'm going to go make myself a morning
cup of coffee like I do
No need no need at all that's sweet Rosa
here we go
hey uh Hey Charles just take my coffee
it's fresh okay I guess I mean if you
don't mind
all right you got it yeah all right no
problem why wouldn't you just use your
other hand
hot coffee in my cats
ah ah cold milk cold milk
oh it's coming out the bottom it is
coming up
so that's 20 cargo ships in the last
three months whoever's behind the
smuggling ring knows their way around
the docks so we're going undercover as
longshoremen I will be Von Tom Tucker a
Gruff spitting Punchy when they got
sailor man who's taking a little break
on dry land but just until my girlfriend
canjula gets out of Lady jail
did you just spit in my trash can no
bonded there's some tobacco in there too
Von choose it but it makes Jake super
dizzy and I'm twink Tucker you cannot
choose your own name anymore I got a job
at the docs to support my drug habit but
I kept it because I love the seagulls
what are you Irish now no well we better
get going Captain don't want to be late
for our shift down to the docks
good news the leader of the cargo
smoking ring turned himself in at the
8-3 the mafia was closing in on
it's great it's good news yeah
case closed I guess we'll just
return these outfits great take this
back you have 10 minutes
coffee extra black extra no sugar and
real warm it gets cold on them Ducks I
want a great tea for me twink Tucker now
you ruined it good morning Diaz for Ulta
Captain you're smiling
it's very weird like seeing a turtle out
of its shell I'm happy our drug task
force was a success and today I get to
watch my Nemesis Madeleine lunch drape a
metal around my neck also we clean up
the streets yeah sure that's good too so
I've been planning how to Zing Madeline
when she puts the metal on I have the
perfect line lunch time is over
so it's a play on lunchtime yes
devastating Burns sir but you know what
would really show her is if you said
nothing at all oh interesting
interestingly let Madeline know she's
not even worth my staying up all night
crafting zingers lunch time took you all
night trust me turn the other cheek
which I recently learned is About Faces
and not butts but works either way
be the bigger person it shouldn't be
hard given that Madeline's not
technically a person for meritorious
service the NYPD bestows this award on
detectives Rosa Diaz Jake Peralta and
Captain
Raymond Holt
Raymond Madeleine you won
go ahead and go out you Toad
thank you for this honor deputy chief
oh
okay
you're welcome
lunch time is over boom did it had it
both ways